let's put the care back into health care
I've been working in the health care
sector
for the last 15 years and one of the
things that drew me to this sector was
my interest in the care component of our
health care systems more specifically to
the invaluable role played by carers now
how many of you in this room consider
yourself a carer by this I mean how many
of you have cared for someone suffering
from an illness injury or disability can
you raise your hand if this is the case
about half of the room I want to thank
all of you who raised your hands for the
time that you've spent as a carer what
you do is extremely precious I am a
former cared for patient myself when I
was a teenager I suffered from Lyme
disease and underwent 18 months of
antibiotic treatment I was repeatedly
misdiagnosed bacterial meningitis
fibromyalgia you name it they couldn't
figure it out and if I'm standing here
in front of you today it's because I owe
my life to the stubbornness and
commitment of one care he did everything
he could for me driving long distances
from one treatment center to another
searching for the best option and above
all never giving up despite the
difficulties he encountered including
from a work and quality of life
perspective that was my father I
recovered and this is largely thanks to
his dedication this experience turned me
into a patient advocate the closer I
looked the more I saw carers providing
the same kind of support that my father
provided to me and playing a crucial
role in the health care system I don't
think it's an exaggeration to say that
without informal carers like him our
health and social systems would crumble
and yet they're largely going
unrecognized
I am now a long-distance carer for my
mother who suffers from multiple chronic
conditions
I understand now more than ever the
demands that caregivers face with ageing
populations economic instability
healthcare system stress and increase
incidence of long-term chronic care
needs the importance and demands on
family caregivers are greater than ever
carers all over the world are
sacrificing their own physical financial
and psychosocial well-being to provide
care for their loved ones carers have
their own limits and needs and in
absence of adequate support many could
be stretched to the breaking point once
seen as a personal and private matter in
family life unpaid caregiving has formed
the invisible backbone of our health and
social systems all over the world many
of these carers are even in this room as
we have just seen who are they and how
many are they what are the challenges
that they are facing and above all how
can we make sure that their value to
patients or health care system and
society is recognized
anyone can be a carer really a 15 year
old girl caring for a parent with
multiple sclerosis a 40 year old man
juggling full-time work while caring for
his family who lives far away a 60 year
old man caring for his wife who has
terminal cancer or an 80 year old woman
caring for her husband who has
Alzheimer's disease the things carers do
for their patients are varied they
provide personal care like getting
someone dressed feeding them helping
them to the bathroom helping them move
about they also provide a significant
level of medical care because they often
know a lot about their their loved ones
condition and needs sometimes better
than the patients themselves who may be
paralyzed or confused by their diagnosis
in those situations carers are also
advocates for the patient also of
critical importance is the fact that
carers also provide emotional support
they organize doctor's appointments they
manage finances and they also deal with
daily household tasks these challenges
are challenges that we can't ignore
there are currently more than 100
million carers providing 80% of care
across Europe and even if these numbers
are impressive they're most likely
underestimated given the lack of
recognition of carers as we have just
seen many of you in this room weren't
sure if you could be qualified or
considered to be a carer many of you
probably thought I was referring to a
nurse or some other health care
professional also stunning are the
benefits that carers bring to our
societies and I want to give you just
one example from Australia in 2015 the
annual value provided by informal carers
to those suffering from mental illness
was evaluated at thirteen point two
billion Australian dollars this is
nearly two times what the Australian
government spends on mental health
services annually these numbers among
others demonstrate that if carers were
to stop caring tomorrow our health and
social systems would crumble
and while the importance of these
millions of silent carers cannot be
denied they've largely been unnoticed by
governments health care systems and
private entities in addition carers are
facing enormous personal challenges many
carers face higher costs and can face
financial difficulties given the fact
that they may not be able to work full
time or they may not be able to hold
down a job altogether many studies have
shown that often carers sacrificed their
own health and well-being in order to
care for their loved ones many carers
spend so much time caring for their
loved ones that often their family and
their relationships can
for many carers report that often their
employers don't have adequate policies
in place to support them there has been
improvement though in the recognition of
carers around the world just a few years
ago an umbrella organization called the
international alliance of terror
organizations or aya Co was formed to
bring together care groups from all over
the world to provide strategic direction
facilitate information sharing as well
as actively advocate for carers on an
international level private entities are
also starting to recognize the situation
of carers
I am proud that my personal engagement
and enthusiasm towards this topic of
carers found an echo in my own workplace
my company is committed to this cause
and has developed an unprecedented
framework for its employees and society
as a whole the objective is to empower
carers to improve their own health and
well-being and bring about a greater
balance to their lives nevertheless much
more needs to be done to complement
these relatively isolated initiatives
our societies are facing increased
health pressures including aging
population increase incident of cancer
and chronic conditions widespread
inequality amongst many others to
confront these challenges policymakers
must look beyond traditional healthcare
pathways and employment policies and
recognise that informal care will
continue to form the bedrock of care
caring for someone should be a choice
and should be done without putting one's
own well-being in the balance but to
really put the care back into health
care what's needed is a deep societal
structural change and this can only
happen through a change in mindset and
this can start today today we can plant
the seed for a change for millions of
carers around the world here's what I
want to suggest when you go home today
or to the office tomorrow morning
embrace a carer thank them offer him or
her a bit of help maybe even volunteer
as a carer yourself for a couple hours a
week if carers around the world felt
better recognized it would not only
improve their own health and well-being
and sense of fulfillment but it would
also improve the lives of those that
they're caring for let's care more thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]